how does the decision-making process in
the Council of the European Union work
well the council is one of the three
main institutions of the EU with the
Commission and the Parliament it has
composed of national government
ministers from each of the 28 member
states ministers represent the interests
of their own democratically accountable
governments the council in the
parliament consider amend negotiate and
adopt EU legislation normally proposed
by the Commission that is the ordinary
legislative procedure also known as Co
decision it sounds simple but it's not
that easy under the ordinary legislative
procedure the council and the Parliament
are on equal footing if they reach
agreement they can adopt the legislation
at first reading if not there is a
second reading if following a second
reading the two institutions still can't
agree a conciliation committee is
convened since 1999 67% of ordinary
legislative procedure files have been
concluded during the first reading 24%
during the second reading and only 9%
through conciliation
there are two other procedures used for
a few specific cases the consent
procedure and the consultation procedure
once adopted certain types of EU
legislation then have to be incorporated
into national law some are directly
applicable others take some time to
become law for the 500 million citizens
of the EU
how can ministers hold their national
jobs and sit in the council well they
get a little help all the work of the
council is prepared or coordinated by
the permanent representatives committee
known as Cora path
Cora power is made up of member state
representatives in addition the council
has more than 150 working parties and
committees who also help few those
ministers are human after all
in short that's how decision making in
the Council of the EU works find out
more on the website at Concilium Roper
dot EU